il combine beaucoup de genres différents.
Je suis vraiment les films sur une
vie artificielle et vous regardez la bataille
pour cette âme de robot d'une certaine manière entre
un côté criminel et un côté plus intellectuel
à la fin du film, c'est en quelque sorte
grandit en intégrant tous ces
différents côtés dans un tout organique
shoo-shoo hey chappie est le
premier robot sensible au monde et il vient
au monde un peu comme un bébé le ferait
donc c'était un défi assez intéressant de
trouver une sorte d'archétype enfantin à
travaillez à mélanger cela avec vous savez ce que
nous appellerions le gangster de Cape Flats
, puis faites-le connaître avec un QI
d'environ 350 au centre de ce film,
je suis sûr que beaucoup de gens parleront
des effets visuels qui ont fait chappie
possible mais je pense que la chose qui
apportera à chappie une vie est courte doit
ses performances et tout
s'inspire de Charlotte, les yeux du robot
bougent ses oreilles bougent et certainement la façon dont
son corps bouge est tout dicté par  la
performance des orteils en coquille,
il a si bien fait ce personnage que
vous ne pouvez pas vous empêcher de fondre, donc agir en
face de lui a été si facile
non, je suis d'accord, souviens-toi de l'accord ouais je t'ai fait
j'ai travaillé sur beaucoup de
gnomes d'effets spéciaux et je '  Je n'ai jamais été dans une
situation où la personne va
être complètement transformée en un effet visuel
est en fait juste active oui
ils portent un costume gris mais certains
ont une partie de mon enfance il y a tellement de
génie et je pense que le design de leur
vrai robot Scout le fait qu'il soit à
peu près de la même taille que lui signifie qu'il
ne jure pas sur des échasses, il n'a pas à
tenir un bâton avec sa balle de tennis sur le dessus,
vous savez que cela semble très réel